what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
thanks so much for stopping by the
channel today right now a lot is
happening in not only the world of
Marvel Studios but in movies and shows
in general as the wga The Writer's Guild
of America has gone on strike so
therefore right now scripts aren't
really being written and of course this
is going to go on to effect production
of a lot of movies and shows that are
going on right now not just with Marvel
Studios of course but in the entire
movie and TV industry just in general
and a quick interesting note about this
according to Insider Daniel rpk the
reason that they haven't really come to
a deal yet is because of Netflix
apparently Netflix did not want to agree
to some terms of the wga that's why the
strike is still going on according to
Daniel rbk as if Netflix wasn't already
kind of causing enough problems with
their new rules about households and
sharings and everything we go and hear
this as well but hopefully things get
resolved soon however some of Marvel
Studios as projects that are in
production right now are on hold however
there is some good news some are still
going and it looks like we have finally
found out when we are going to be
getting our new Avengers team we haven't
really heard much about the new Avengers
team who's gonna be on it when they're
going to start to come together but the
project that they're supposed to come in
together on is still in production right
now that has not been delayed so that is
good news and also we have some big news
about the directors or Secret Wars right
now Avengers Secret Wars does not have a
director attached to it but there are a
few names thrown out there who could
possibly direct and there is one
director in particular that fans are
really pushing for and have been pushing
for and now the director himself is
pushing for him to direct the film he
wants to do it and he directed a very
very successful Marvel movie so as you
see a lot to dive into today and if you
love Marvel be sure to subscribe to the
channel and hit that notification Bell
we talk about Marvel every single day we
also have a really good giveaway going
on we'll talk about that at the end and
also don't forget to check out our
patreon our website and our Discord
we'll link those in the comment and
description down below now like I said
unfortunately and we'll start with bad
news and go into the good news
unfortunately some projects have been
delayed from Marvel Studios and just
marvel in general for example the Marvel
Spider-Man series that are going to
Amazon Spider-Man Noir and silk spider
Society Unfortunately they are kind of
shut down right now until the wga
reaches a deal so those two projects
right now are currently just paused
they're not being worked on there's no
progression right now they're kind of
just playing the waiting game and the
same thing goes for a Marvel Studios
project unfortunately which is the
Thunderbolts but it's actually not that
bad it's not as bad as it seems because
the Thunderbolts movie is going to be
coming after Captain America new world
order or Captain America four there's
been a rumor that it's no longer being
called New World Order but we haven't
heard anything official yet but the good
news is Captain America 4 comes out
before the Thunderbolts and Captain
America 4 luckily is not delayed right
now production is still currently going
on in fact over the last couple of
months we have many set photos and some
set videos showing Sam Wilson's Captain
America and his new Captain America suit
and we've actually seen pictures of the
new Falcon Sam's old buddy Taurus who is
going to be played by Danny Ramirez who
we saw in the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier so Sam Wilson is officially
going to be Captain America and have his
own Falcon which is great because Falcon
has always been somebody extremely close
to Captain America but here's where this
gets really cool Captain America 4 is
supposed to bring together a lot of
different worlds in fact it's supposed
to be the start of the new Avengers
roster now what's interesting is that
the Thunderbolts is essentially going to
do the same after Captain America 4.
they're going to bring a lot of
different worlds together however the
roster is for a very different team but
variety has recently reported that the
Thunderbolts is hold but they do also
report how all of these worlds are going
to start to collide stating on their
website the movie was scheduled to begin
shooting in Atlanta next month and plans
to resume production after the strike is
resolved part of Marvel's Phase 5
Thunderbolts is set to bring together
the worlds of Ant-Man and the WASP the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier Black
Widow and the upcoming Captain America
installment New World Order and that is
essentially what is going to be
happening for the new Avengers team as
well in Captain America 4. the
Thunderbolts will bring together the
Thunderbolt so when it talks about
bringing together Ant-Man and the WASP
with Falcon and the Winter Soldier
they're talking about bringing together
the character ghost with us agent John
Walker and when they talk about Black
Widow coming into play they're talking
about of course Yolanda Bulova and
Taskmaster but when we flip that and
talk about the new Avengers team which
is going to assemble in Captain America
4 before the Thunderbolts we're talking
about Ant-Man of course Captain America
and one of the biggest care characters
that has been rumored to be appearing in
Captain America 4 is the Hulk in fact
many insiders have said that we're going
to possibly see several hulks in Captain
America 4 and of course we're all
thinking right now Red Hulk so the Hulk
returning hopefully Spider-Man Doctor
Strange I'm sure is going to stop by
somewhere and of course we can't forget
about war machine he's going to be up to
a lot but just like the Thunderbolts is
going to bring together all of these
worlds Captain America 4 is going to be
the start of the new Avengers team where
we get a glimpse on how they're all
going to be interacting with each other
so luckily right now Captain America 4
is still on track it's still in
production now Marvel Studios is known
to do rewrites in the middle of
production so if that happens we might
hit a snag but for right now everything
is okay and luckily Marvel really kind
of has to deal with Captain America 4
first before they dive into the
Thunderbolt so right now Thunderbolts
being on hold is kind of okay not too
much delay should really happen there
but speaking of the new Avengers diving
into Avengers Secret Wars like I
mentioned it seems like there are a few
director names out there right now who
could possibly get the job at directing
one of if not maybe the biggest Marvel
Studios movie of all time now the first
one we'll talk about is director Destin
Daniel if you are not familiar
with him he directed Shang Chi and the
legend of the 10 Rings like I mentioned
this director directed a film that many
people love from Marvel and phase 4
nonetheless which was not received that
well but Shang Chi was chongqi is one of
my top five favorite Marvel movies which
really is hard to say because that list
does change from time to time but
according to Insider Jeff Snyder on the
John Roca podcast today he said that
director Destin Daniel wants to
direct Secret Wars he also threw out
some other names of who are possible
candidates to direct the movie and one
name he threw out that I really really
love is Jon Favreau who of course
started the MCU with the very first Iron
Man film he's also been a very integral
part of the m SEO and Star Wars
franchise as well Marvel loves him Star
Wars loves him Disney loves him he is
the future of both Marvel and Star Wars
but unfortunately even though he is a
great Contender to direct Avenger Secret
Wars it sounds like from what Jeff
Snyder said he's pretty locked up by
Kathleen Kennedy in Star Wars he's got a
lot of Star Wars stuff to do I gotta say
though he would probably be my choice to
direct this movie he's been with the MCU
since Iron Man he's been a big part of
it growing and expanding he's definitely
got the vision I would definitely love
for him to direct this film but one last
name a Jeff Snyder throughout today was
Sam Raimi who is possibly the biggest
director that Marvel Studios has worked
with now I know some people right away
would say well Multiverse Madness was
not that good but let's be honest that
movie was kind of a mess production wise
they had a writer Scott Derrickson he
wrote an entire script they parted ways
with him then they brought in Michael
Waldron and Sam Remy they had to make a
lot of changes they had to rewrite
essentially almost the entire script and
it's just not a great environment to go
into when Marvel has already decided on
kind of a base for the movie and some
key points that you have to use but then
come in and make it your own and
Elizabeth Olsen actually recently
expressed frustration in all of the
script rewrites so that really wasn't on
Sam Raimi however I can say that Michael
Waldron who wrote Multiverse of Madness
and who wrote Loki season 1 is writing
Secret Wars so if Remy came back that
would be the exact same team from
Multiverse of Madness it would be the
same writer and director but them
getting their own project from scratch
writing it the way they want with of
course supervision from Kevin feige I
think would be just fine I think it
could be really good but I think right
now the tier list for me would be John
Favreau Dustin Daniel krepton and then
Sam Raimi but let us know your thoughts
about this in the comments down below do
you have a director you would prefer out
of these listed or is there a directory
you have in mind that is not talked
about in this video please let us know
all your thoughts down below please
don't forget to like the video and if
you subscribe and leave a comment you're
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items the
winner gets to pick one item and we pick
a winner at the end of each month we're
almost at the end of this month so a
winner will be picked soon you can also
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
me